to brothers. Let me summarize why we
went to the Hebrew Israelites. I know
very well they don't listen. Okay,
they're very very delusional people.
Literally, I spoke to them before. The
reason because they were speaking to
some Muslim sisters. So, I went there
also show the people what they believe
in doesn't make any sense. So, some
people might think why I should see you
shouting. I know them. If you speak them
very low, they will eat you,
>> you know. They will overshout you. They
will shut you down. They will not let
you speak. So you have to raise your
voice. You understand even you can see
they will raise their voices too. Anyway
the point here is he told me clearly God
does not contradict himself and told me
the Bible is the word of God. When I
show contradiction instead of accepting
it and saying let me double check he was
trying to justify it in a way doesn't
make any sense. What it shows you they
are like sheep blind followers. That's
why you should come to Islam. Islam
gives you Islam free your mind from
slavery of society and shaitan and
desires. You become a slave of the true
most high Allah subhana wa ta'ala. So
even remember what he said he said every
emotion that we have god have but we
have deficiency in us.
>> So go have see that show you have
deficiency
>> because basically Hebrew Israelite is a
movement trying to utilize religion to
justify their racism like a nation of
Islam like a chemist you know. So
anyway, may Allah guide them because
even know maybe one of them will go back
home and think about it. So
alhamdulillah Islam is the truth.
Alhamdulillah. Even he said I'm sure him
in the Bible says to kill babies and
children. When I told you about God
regrets and he said I don't know what it
means regret. Everyone knows what it
means regret. Anyway, may Allah guide
him. But just to let you know the reason
I was raising my ways you have to do it
this way.
Go to the Bible. What you believe?
>> Genesis chapter 10. We believe what the
Bible says. Someone
>> does the Bible teaches you?
>> Bible.
>> Does the Bible teaches you like African
devils?
>> We're going to do things decently and in
order. If you have a question, I'm going
to read a scripture. You're going to get
your answer. Be patient.
>> If I don't agree with scripture,
>> the book of Genesis chapter 10 and verse
one. Now, these are the generations of
the sons of Noah. Shem, Ham, and Jaffin.
>> Right. Noah had three sons.
>> That's right.
>> Shem and jump to verse six. I'm going to
read about descendants of Ham.
>> But I'm not asking you about
descendants. Sick.
>> Why you asking the question?
>> And descendants of Ham.
>> Why are you asking the question?
>> And Midra.
>> So the descendants of Ham were the
natural Africans. They were the first
inhabitants.
>> So are they devils or not? Cuz you sit.
You're from the Samite.
>> I know you're like Arab.
>> Now wait before you tell me what a devil
means.
>> What does the word devil?
>> You believe the black Africans are
devils or not. I know you believe the
word devil.
>> I know you're shy to say that openly.
You believe the worst man is the devil.
Okay. are the the black as could you
believe they sold you out the white man
you the reason you believe you are the
true Hebrew is a lie before you go to
the Bible I know the Bible very well get
my Bible please
>> get my Bible please
>> I'm going to read the Bible
debate of course you're just having
discussion but I'm asking simply if I
say to you something can ask a question
are the black African devil
>> your question answer your question
>> the book of first John chapter 3 and
verse 8
>> he that committeth sin Sin is of the
devil.
>> So guess what? Anybody that commits sin
is of the devil.
>> The devil.
>> Are you devil? They
>> can be. Are you devilized?
>> They can be.
>> So are devil as well.
>> Listen. Anybody?
>> Look, you're not asking that question.
>> I'm not asking question. I'm asking. Are
you Are you
asking question to get somewhere?
>> No. No.
>> I'm asking you are the black Africans
devils or not?
>> My sister,
>> are the black devils or not? The black
Africans. He wants to debate.
>> Everyone that commit sin is not a devil.
>> What's the Bible say? Read it again.
First John chapter 3
wait
3 and verse 8. He that committh sin.
>> He that committh sin the other one.
>> Okay. I have the Bible here by the way.
The devil. I have the Bible here.
>> We heard that one. All right. We heard
it. We heard it loud and clear. Okay.
Now, next question. Next question. Okay.
Do you believe the Bible is the word of
God?
>> Yes, 100%.
>> Does God contradict himself?
>> No.
>> If I show you contradiction in the
Bible, now what are you going to do?
>> We're going to prove you wrong.
>> Okay. I'm going to show him
contradictions within the Bible.
>> Let's go.
>> Okay. I have the Bible contradiction.
Okay. So, we have
>> real quick.
>> Okay. You have 36.
>> Wait, wait, wait. We heard you out. No,
wait, wait. We heard you out.
>> We heard you out. Let us have at least
>> our time.
>> I know it's a bit hard, but just give us
a couple seconds. is the truth.
>> Is that anyway? I'm going to Am I going
to read history?
>> Okay, I'm going to
Let's Let's just set order first. I like
>> No, no, no. We tell you order. We tell
you order. It's our turn.
>> We gave you your turn.
>> All right. Next time. Next time. Get to
it.
>> Get to it. Get to it. cuz they're going
to dance around all day.
>> First Corinthians
>> before he gives you the first not
>> where's the order's
you can't teach us. We're going to give
you the remember
to
>> I'm going to show you contradiction in
the Bible. There's a contradiction in
the Bible. Are you scared of the
contradiction or not? So let me read it.
Let me read it before I show you. Let me
read it.
>> This is the book of first Corinthians.
Do you hear a voice of order?
Let all things be done decently. Let all
in order and in order. Let all things be
done decently and in order. This book is
a book of order. One by one.
>> Okay. One by one. All right. One by one.
So now I want to listen to you. Thank
you very much. I want to listen to what
you what's the contradiction that we're
talking about.
>> I want you all to listen.
>> You got to say to
>> No, no, no. You're wasting time now.
Listen. Listen. Don't get distracted.
This is your point.
>> He's been shouting at me.
>> Wait, wait. Listen. This is your turn to
speak. He shout. He's talking.
All things been done decently. Thank you
very much.
>> So just saying what your contradiction
is.
>> I'm going to remember. Now it's my turn
to speak. I've asked him simple
question. I asked his friend. He left.
No problem. He just took over. He
didn't. He's here right now. I'm talking
to you. Let's go.
>> So I'm saying here
the Bible is the word of God. Yes.
>> I'm going to show you. I have a Bible
here, King James. Okay. I told him,
"Does God contradict himself?" He said,
"No." So, I'm going to read to you a
contradiction. They're not just one.
There's many of them in the Bible. I'm
going to give you one now. So, now let
us read
Chronicles. Okay. Chronicles.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. 36 9
>> 369. Yeah.
>> It says here, listen. It says here.
>> Yes.
>> Second one. Sorry. Second Chronicles.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. 36 the numbers
>> number nine.
>> So he mentions here about king
>> called Johashin. Yeah.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Dashin was 80 years old when he became a
king. Remember how old he was?
>> Yeah.
>> Yes. Yes. 80 years old. Go
wait.
>> Man of order. No order.
>> Let me speak.
>> Come on.
>> He's shouting.
We are men. We shout. Excuse me. No.
Wait. Wait. Wait. Wait. Don't worry.
When you shout, you want to say don't
shout.
>> Don't worry. I want every Get out of
here, man.
>> Subhan Allah.
>> Get out of here.
>> Anyway, now I'm going to Kings.
>> All right. Same Bible. Now I'm going to
Kings. And you can check it online.
>> I'm going to Kings 248.
>> And you're going to hear how old Josh
was when he became a king.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. One second.
>> Uh,
take your time. I'm going to take
>> I want everyone to listen because what
he's saying is that there is a
contradiction in the scriptures, right?
He's talking about contradictions in the
scriptures. I want him to speak and then
I will set it straight. Set the record
straight.
>> 248.
>> Yep.
>> Go on.
>> Uh 248.
>> Listen.
>> Uh 248. Yeah. Yeah. 24.
>> Got to know where you're going to go on.
>> Yeah, of course, Bab. Don't worry.
>> Yeah.
>> Here we go. Jehosh was 18 years old when
he became a king.
>> Okay.
>> Is 18 different than eight or not? Yes,
it is. He was 8 years. So, how old was
he according to the Bible? Was he 8
years old or he was 18 years old for you
now?
>> Okay. Very good. Now, I want to ask you
a question. Whether he was 8 years old
or whether he was 18 years old, what
difference does it make to keeping God's
laws?
>> I'll tell you what difference. It shows
you that God doesn't know how old the
man was. It shows you what is ignorance.
No, no, no. You ask me a question. You
see what he did? What he's doing
indirectly affirming there's
contradiction by his argument even
though there's a contra Let me finish.
Allow me to finish. His argument even
there's a contradiction yet does not
affect the law of God. It does affect
it. Why? How can you trust God who has a
perfect knowledge? He didn't know how
old was Jerusalem, how old he was.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you. Thank you very much. That
shows you what? So it's for the word of
God.
>> My brother, you made your point, right?
>> Go to Psalm 68.
Listen your point. So good. Go to Psalm
68:1. Read that.
>> Wait, wait, wait. You understand that
point first? I understand. You
understand? My point is that in one
place it says 8 years old and in the
other place it says 18 years old. That
is your point. And that's a wait. That's
what you're saying.
>> Accept it. accept it.
>> Just listen. I want you to listen.
>> Yes, I accept. That's what it
listen
to. Listen. Everyone got to listen.
Let's listen to this now. This is the
important part. Listen. Block.
>> I shall because I want to listen.
>> That's no problem. Don't worry. That's
not a problem.
>> Listen.
>> The book of chapter 68.
>> Brothers.
This is the part you need to listen to.
>> All right. This is the part you need to
listen to.
>> The Lord gave the word.
>> The Lord gave the word. Now listen. I
want you to listen. The Lord gave the
word. Great with the company of those
that
listen. I want you to listen. I want you
to listen. Please listen. I want you to
listen. Listen. The Bible is a book that
was published by men. Do you understand
that? King
James translated the Bible, right?
Translated. He didn't write it. He
translated it. But the original
manuscripts of the Bible were written by
men. You understand? Now, now I want you
to listen very carefully. Right. Go
ahead. Help yourself for me.
>> All right. Go ahead. Read.
>> Psalms 68 and verse 11. The Lord gave
the wordh.
>> Great was the company of those that
published it.
>> Now, those who published the Bible, the
company of them was great. Is telling
you that there's 1,500
years span of different people writing
different from different places in
different languages, Hebrew, Latin,
Greek, but all of them were writing by
the inspiration of God. And all those
books when compiled, when compared, all
of them say exactly the same thing. All
of them, listen, I gave you the Give me
the other Bible.
>> I want you to listen. I have another
Bible here.
>> I want you to listen. Sorry. Sorry.
Sorry. All of them said the same thing.
In other words, they were all concise
and they were all correlating one
another. They didn't know one another.
They lived in different times. They
lived in different places. But the the
truth right came to each one of them and
they wrote in their different places and
when one man compared it with the other
they saw that thou shalt not steal here
is still thou shalt not steal there and
it's still thou shall not steal in Iran
and is thou shall not steal in London
and is thou shall not steal in America
the same laws apply right is it 18 years
old listen
is it 18 years old is it 8 years old is
unfallible. Yes. But is the word of God
fallible? No.
>> So that's the word of God.
Sister, please. Yes. Come to sister.
>> This is my point.
>> God doesn't know. Sister, if his God
doesn't know, how is going to know?
>> I want you to listen. I want you to
listen.
>> Sister, if his God doesn't know, how is
going to know? Listen, listen. I want
you to understand something, right?
>> He's just making it up.
When the scripture is speaking, listen.
When the scripture is finished,
>> listen. when the scripture is speaking
go to uh uh
>> no before you go to you just brother you
mentioned some point so we have to deal
with it
>> I'm dealing with
>> no you're not dealing with yeah but the
problem is essay
brother oh but you're going off topic no
step by step it's an essay you just said
you remember what he said he said even
though the writers of the Bible never
met each other he said the exact let me
finish the exact thing I just showed him
in the Bible there is contradiction so
the writer of the
He did not say the same thing the writer
of. So he just made it up. Let me
finish. Let me finish. Let me finish. He
just made it up. Remember the question
of ask him. I said to him, is the Bible
the word of God? He said yes. I said
that contradict himself. He said no. And
I showed him a clear contradiction
instead of deal with the contradiction.
We're just preaching. Alhamdulillah.
Allah the Quran. Allah said if the book
of Allah was from Allah you will find a
lot of contradictions. That's why
there's no contradiction in the Quran
>> about us here. Understand you're not
going to over
>> second Peter chapter 1 and verse 20.
>> Knowing this verse that no prophecy of
the scripture is of any private
interpretation.
>> So no prophecy of the scripture is of
any private interpretation. Let us
listen to what the scripture was written
for. Is it about the debate between
numbers here or there? What is Bro,
you're making no sense. Listen,
>> bro. You're making no sense, man. 21
prophecy came not in all time by the
will of man.
>> I just show him there's mistakes in the
Bible instead of dealing with it. He
just preaching God's
move.
>> As they were moved. Uhhuh. All right.
Read on. And by the Holy Ghost.
>> Okay, bro. Can you help me please?
>> Uh 316. my hand a good job
that the the scriptures were listen the
scriptures were written by man now were
there errors mistakes here and there
that is not the point that's the point
that's point
I'm telling you the point of the
scripture
so you're diverting them listen if you
don't listen you don't get it listen if
I want to talk to you today if I don't
speak good English can I still tell tell
you not to steal. Can I still tell you
not to kill?
>> If you know how to say it.
>> Good. Good. So, so, so I'm I'm saying to
you that the point of the scriptures is
not about good English. The point of the
scriptures is about
talking about English. Listen, listen.
Listen, I want you to know. Don't worry.
I know where you go with. I know very
well. I know you very well.
>> Listen. I stud for last 5 years.
>> Listen, listen. Okay. So now I sit down
and I'm writing someone is talking right
and they say one person says eight
another person says 18. Do you
understand? If I write eight or I write
18 does it change what the laws of God
are saying?
>> No my so let me feel let me know it's my
you've been speaking for long. So
firstly that's why when I came to you I
spoke to you in a respectful way. I said
to you
people listen yes listen. So listen to
me. Listen to me now. So my question
sister sister one second
>> a minute to make your point as well
too.
here to treat your boy.
Listen, listen. Listen, listen.
Arant, listen. Anyway, what say
anyway? What can I say to you? Listen
carefully. I as a question. I said, is
the Bible the word of God? You said yes.
>> I said, does does God contradict
himself? You said no. If the Bible is
the word of God, therefore there will be
no contradiction in the Bible. Let me
speak. I just showed you. You just told
me. Let me speak. Let me speak. I just
showed him contradiction in the Bible.
Instead of saying, you know what? Let me
step back and think twice. Allow me.
Allow me. Let me finish. You keep
cutting me. Instead
of liean
okay instead of thinking you know what
it's clear contradiction I should think
about it twice because I just told God
does not contradict himself and show me
from my own scripture God did contradict
himself what you said you said the right
is then infallible they make mistakes
but if you accept the right of the Bible
they put it wrong sometimes they make
mistakes Sometimes how can you trust it?
Because you already establish upon
yourself there is mistakes which the
right is finished bro the right have
said. So that's why that's allow me to
speak. No that's why in Islam
alhamdulillah Allah wants to show that
the Quran is the speech of Allah he's
dead if you if there's any contradiction
in the Quran you will never find any.
Why you scared of the truth? Why you
scared of the truth? Why you scared
little brother? You took it back to the
law.
>> I took it to the law.
>> You took it back to the law.
>> We took it back to the number.
>> But even let me finish. Let me finish.
He said you should not kill. In the
Bible, in the Bible it says to kill
babies. To kill I'm finishing. You just
said in the Bible himself. Correct. In
the Bible said don't kill. Correct. But
in the Bible also said to kill babies
and children. Okay. So in a woman I read
the context. Let me read the context.
Hold this. In the Bible, he tells you to
kill a baby. In Islam, you don't allow
to kill a baby. In the Bible, he said to
kill a woman. In Islam, you don't kill a
woman. Forbidden experience Islam
killing.
>> That's not Islam. They're wrong. That's
not
your
point. The Quran is The Quran says to
kill women to kill children. Okay. Okay.
Good argument. That's a good argument.
Come. Come. That's a good argument. No.
The point. The point. The point here.
Listen carefully. The point. I'm not
telling you because you're not perfect.
You can't make me sick. I'm talking. No.
Listen carefully. I'm talking about the
source. Your source tells you to kill
babies and children. Islamic source said
do not kill a baby and children. So your
thoughts I think ISIS ISIS were the
followers of the Bibleis
ban
very good arguments two questions that
you asked you understand the first
question you asked you said is it 8 or
18 right and because of that can we
trust the Bible I want you to listen
>> if I make listen argument listen that's
the argument
>> no no don't misin wait
>> don't misrepresent Listen, listen to
this. The argument here, I want you to
listen because you are the one saying
it.
>> Go ahead.
>> You said is it 8 or 18, right? You're
following, right? Is it 8 or 18 years
old?
>> And the argument is if it is not 8 or
18, like if there's a mistake there,
then you cannot trust the source. Is
that the argument?
>> No, no, no, no. The s the problem is I
told you that God pushes himself. You
told me the Bible is the word of God.
I'm not saying don't trust everything in
there. Well, I'm just showing you one
point. I'm showing you in the Bible
which you believe is the word of God.
There's contradiction.
>> That's not a contradiction.
>> So, how do they can they both be right?
Can they both be right?
>> Yes, they can. Listen. Listen.
Now, you're playing games. How?
>> So, you can become a king and eight or
eight at the same time. Alhamdulillah
for Islam. Alhamdulillah for Islam. Go
ahead.
>> Let me explain it to you. Go ahead. Go
ahead. In one part of the Bible, it says
there were 40,000 chariots.
>> Go ahead. charoteers,000
and listen another place he said 4,000.
I know that
>> but you can have one record the number
of people it takes to ride a chariot and
you can have another one record the
chariots. Do you understand? So the
context matters. Do we know the context?
Here I know the context here. Here's the
context. Read it. Read the context.
>> Listen listen.
The context the context of scriptures
right is the laws of God to teach you
how to live not necessarily how to count
numbers to teach you how to live a
question. But if the people ask question
if the people are inspired by God they
shouldn't make that mistake. If they are
inspired by God they should not make
that mistake. You would realize
eventually that that was not necessary.
Let me just ask that it's not a mistake.
Now say that but listen
>> here it says of joy was 8 years old when
he became a king and reigned in
Jerusalem 3 months and 10 days. So the
same sorry shouting as well.
>> We Africans without shouting.
>> Africa said don't shout.
>> If I say this if you could ask this for
me then understand. Yeah.
>> Good.
>> God Yeah. has a set of rules and laws.
Yes.
>> Say go on. Say it again.
>> God has rules and rules.
>> So God has laws and rules. Yeah. It's
not going to be changed.
>> It's not going to be changed. Yes. Yes.
>> You cannot be different than his rules
and laws. Yeah. Yes. Go on.
>> If you are a father,
>> Uhhuh.
>> would you have your son be killed for
him who raped a woman? Huh?
>> Right.
>> Listen. Yeah.
>> Who raped a a boy?
>> Okay.
Just me. Yeah. Who raped a Who raped a
boy? Who raped a woman and then he
killed him? Would you kill your son?
Yeah. For my mistake. No, let me finish.
Let me finish it. Let me finish it.
Yeah. For my mistake. Yeah. And that's
your son and daughter being done like
that, brother.
>> Good. Good. Would you do that?
>> I understand. Would you do that?
Let me answer your question.
You are preparing apples and oranges.
You're giving less than life sacrifices.
Listen, listen. You start sacrificing.
Listen, I want you to You've asked a
question. I want you to listen to the
answer. How about you to
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. They asking us
and I'm here to listen. Right.
>> Are you Are you here to listen?
Obviously.
>> So, listen. Listen.
>> Right. The cont brother no it's not
different it's not different all of
these people yeah listen to me brother
how can different clan
>> you are comparing comparing brother you
said Jesus sacrifice
man listen
>> you say Jesus for all our sins I was
going to show you more contradictions
you know go to
>> there's more contradictions there's more
contradictions
I want you to listen to the reason
Before
we go to that, I'll show you more. No,
you're not. You ask the question.
I'm going to show you more. Does God
regret?
>> Does God regret?
>> Listen, you don't understand what regret
means.
>> God has everything.
>> God has Listen, you're asking me a
question, but you're not listening. You
don't understand what regret means. Let
me explain.
>> Regret mean English language. Every
single emotion that man has, God has. Is
he is he jealous? Yes. Is it does he
regret? Yes. Every single emotion. Why?
That's why you have those emotions.
>> Regret is deficiency. Regret is
deficiency. Only for deficiency for God
forget. You know why? Because regret
regrets when you know the outcome of
something. That's why you regret it. In
the Bible said God greatly regret. Let
me finish. Let me finish please to
understand. In the Bible said God
greatly regrets for choosing Saul as a
king. So God is know that Saul he's
going to take and guess him. So
therefore your God doesn't have a
perfect knowledge. That's why I'm saying
I'm sure you cannot trust the Bible. He
has many problems there.
>> Listen to what the Listen
Corinthians chapter 6 and verse 9.
>> This is what we're here for. Listen.
Know ye not that the unrighteous shall
not inherit the kingdom of God?
>> The unrighteous man is not going to
inherit the kingdom of God. The kingdom
of God is coming. Christ listen. The
kingdom of God is coming. The
unrighteous man is not going to inherit
it. Listen. Be not deceived.
>> Don't be deceived. Don't be sidetracked
by 8 or 18 by numbers. Don't be
deceived.
>> So basically be a blind follower. Listen
follower. That's what I mean. Be sheep.
Islam for those who are fornicators.
Listen. If you're sleeping around mount
one woman to another, this is not going
to inherit the kingdom of God. Listen.
Read.
>> Neither fornicators.
>> No fornicators.
>> Not idolattors.
>> Not idolattors. If you are worshiping
other gods, if you're bowing down to a
rock in Mecca, if you're bowing,
>> why you changing the subject, man?
That's the weakest argument ever.
>> You pray. No, you pray to a rock in the
Bible. Jacob put a rock and pray toward
him. That is in the Bible.
That's why speak to me cuz I know his
Bible. I know the Bible. He doesn't want
to speak to me. Baba screaming and he
go adulterers.
>> Adulterers. Those who sleep in
they are not good at my question. Is it
okay to epheminate?
>> Those who are effeminate. Those who act
men who act like women, they will not
enter the kingdom of God. We
>> no abusers of themselves with mankind.
>> Those who abuse themselves with mankind,
man to man, woman to woman, leaving the
natural youth, they will not enter the
kingdom of God free.
>> No. Thieves.
>> Thieves. If you steal, you are not going
to enter the kingdom of God. You have an
opportunity to repent.
>> Yeah, but you're preaching now, man.
>> But you are not going to enter the
kingdom.
>> You're preaching, brother. to kill
babies.
>> Ask a question. Is it okay to kill
babies?
>> Let me explain something.
>> No. Yes. Muslim. Is it okay to kill
babies? Okay. Is it okay to kill babies?
Is it okay to kill babies?
>> I want you to listen. Is it okay to kill
babies? No. Answer my question. Is it
okay to kill babies?
>> In Islam, it's not okay to kill babies.
The Bible says to kill babies. Listen.
Ask him a question. Is it okay to kill
babies
to kill babies?
>> Extortion.
He's scared. And you know what? You
would do good in politics. You don't
answer the question.
You got to fuse it and please don't cut
it for all of it. When you come in
intellectually, sexually finish you. Do
you have your Quran before the Quran? Do
you have your Quran?
>> Is it okay to kill babies?
>> Do you have your Quran?
>> I want you to listen. Answer my
question. I have Quran.
Get your Quran. Is it okay to kill
babies? Have your Quran.
Answer that question.
>> No. No. Answer my question now.
They want you to listen to what you're
trying to do. They're dealing with
Jesus.
>> And the Bible says it's okay to kill
babies. In the Bible, it says to kill
women and children. Finish. This is the
same thing that they did with Jesus.
What?